for me
so
so
thank you
so
foreign come on
is
oh
much
good morning dear colleagues
the sitting is open one announcement
from my side
uh in relation to the decisions by the
pesh impor and libre committees to enter
into winter
negotiations pursuant to rule
71 paragraph 1 announced at the opening
of the sitting
last monday 2nd of may
i have received the requests for vote in
parliament pursuant to rule 71 paragraph
2 from the id and ecr groups
reaching at least the medium threshold
on the decisions of the liber committee
to enter into negotiations on the two
proposes for regulations concerning
the eu digital covet certificate
and the votes will be held tomorrow
concerning the other decisions to enter
into negotiations i have received no
request
for a vote in parliament by members or a
political group or groups reaching at
least the medium threshold and therefore
the committees may have started
may start the negotiations on the basis
of these
reports
the next item
on the agenda is a council and
commission statements the social
and economic consequences for the
european union of the russian war
in ukraine reinforcing the european
union's capacity to act
i'll start by giving the floor to
bridget the clincare for the council
appreciate you have the
thank
flaw
madam president of the european
parliament president of the european
commission
ladies and gentlemen members of the
parliament
the united nations agency for refugees
believes that over four
five million ukrainian civilians have
already left their country
due to military aggression from russia
during the last informal meeting in
versailles
the heads of state and government in
europe
have
firmly condemned the unjustified
military intervention and unprovoked
aggression from russia against ukraine
and they reaffirmed that the european
union and its member states will
continue to provide political financial
material and humanitarian aid in a
coordinated manner
the member states
have made significant coordinated
efforts to take in millions of refugees
beyond the humanitarian crisis
it has also inevitably led to the
slowdown of the post-coveted recovery
period
coordinated european actions have
allowed us to offset the worst of the
social and economic consequences but
there are still major challenges ahead
of us
this
wage wave of refugees will undoubtedly
have budgetary
consequences which are difficult to
estimate for the european union and its
member states particularly
the member states that border ukraine
however it represents an opportunity for
the european union if refugees want to
integrate in a long-term manner into the
labor market into their host countries
in april we adopted a budget which would
allow us to mobilize different european
funds in order to finance the
welcome of ukrainian refugees
for example investing in education
employment housing health care child
care services and also in
basic material assistance
furthermore on the 4th of march the
council unanimously adopted an
implementing decision which would allow
us to
set up temporary
protection for people fleeing war in
ukraine
and will ensure human harmonized rights
throughout the european union
while ensuring that there is a fair
share of the effort being made between
member states
it's the right to live and work in the
european union but also to have access
to social care
some member states are also providing
financial support to refugees when they
arrive
in order to provide support for
[Music]
school-aged children they will have
access to national education systems
adults can have access to training
courses and integration into the label
market through the active implementation
of public services for employment and uh
involving social partners
in economic terms the russian aggression
against ukraine
the sanctions and counter measures their
impact on the
value and transport chains and
the um
cuts to international transport these
are also going to have an impact on the
european economy that's already been
weakened by the covert 19 crisis and
this will this will be a
long-term impact
raw materials such as wheat cereals and
energy will be affected increasing
inflation in the eu is going to impact
our businesses
as well as energy supply and security
and we will have to fight against
certain shortages um as a priority
the member states in versailles
agreed to reduce
member states dependence on gas
and oil
and coal from russia as well as on their
dependence on fossil fuels
in order to
be freer from gas prom and in order to
ensure supply chains europe has to
diversify its supply to accelerate the
production of green energy to ensure
that they have a joint purchasing for
energies and reduce demand at the same
time we have to maintain our
competitiveness on the global level
in the long term
even though we are seeing higher energy
costs
reducing our dependency
will require a certain number of actions
such as the digital and green
transitions under the french presidency
the council
is doing everything it can to ensure the
supply of gas in
the coming winter
therefore it's necessary to ensure
strong european solidarity and to ensure
that we respect the sanctions that we
have set
i also welcome
the fact that the commission will be
presenting the repower eu program on the
18th of may
in order to
take european
joint actions in favor of
more affordable safer and more
sustainable energy
we are at a historic turning point in
terms of our
energy
independence and our transition
the green transition will provide new
opportunities for jobs and in the long
term it will free us from our end energy
independency that is holding us back
clearly these social um
short-term effects particularly for the
most vulnerable have to be re-examined
in light of the current situation and
how it evolves currently
this transition is our only viable
solution therefore we have to
accelerate our efforts on energy
efficiency on renewables and on hydrogen
energy poverty today affects
about 34 million people in the european
union
that's about one in five people whose
income is below the poverty threshold
they declare that they can not afford to
properly
heat their home
as we announced in the 50 45 package
in order to ensure a fair transition
towards climate neutrality the
commission has
said that it will examine the
green transition's impact on the social
sector and on employment
the commission has also undertaken
discussions
in view of the final adoption of
recommendations which will
ensure a
fair transition towards climate
neutrality and which will also fight
energy poverty
and will ensure targeted actions for
individuals to ensure that they have
essential energy services we will have
further monitoring of the implementation
of the fair transition and particularly
looking at its impact on the most
marginalized groups and those most at
risk of energy poverty
some member states have also
already
ensured access to energy for the most
vulnerable groups as a priority
in line with a target 20 of the european
social goals
we have to act in a decisive manner in
order to fight against the worst effects
of the conflict on our societies and our
economies and ensuring that we show
solidarity and unity between member
states and our actions our priority has
to be
protecting and consolidating our
economic and social model
at the same time ensuring that nobody is
left behind thank you all very much
[Applause]
and now i invite the president of the
european commission ursula on their line
to take the floor
thank you madam president roberta
minister honorable members
next week we will mark europe day it is
the 72nd birthday of our union
and
on this europe day we will talk about of
course the future of our union how we
make it stronger more resilient
closer to the people
but the answer to all these questions we
cannot give alone alone in these days
the answer is also given in ukraine
it is given in kharkiv where ukrainian
first responders venture into the combat
zone
to help those wounded by russian attacks
it is given in the small town of bucha
where survivors are coping with the
atrocities
committed against civilians by russian
soldiers
and it is given these days in mario paul
where ukrainians are resisting a russian
force which greatly outnumbers them
because they are fighting to reaffirm
basic ideas
that they are the master of their future
and not a foreign leader
that it is the international law that
counts and not the right of might
and that poutine must pay a price a high
price for his brutal aggression
thus the future of our european union is
also written in ukraine
and therefore
today i would like to speak about two
topics
first about sanctions
and second about relief and
reconstruction for ukraine
today we are presenting our sixth
package of sanctions
first we are listing high-ranking
military officers and individuals who
committed war crimes in butcher
and those who are responsible for the
inhuman siege of the city of mario paul
this sends another important signal to
all perpetrators of the kremlin
we know who you are we will hold you
accountable you're not getting away with
this
second
we finally d swift spare bank
spare bank is one of the is the largest
russian bank it holds round about 37
percent of the whole banking sector
and we will also d swift to other major
banks in russia
by that we hit banks that are
systemically critical to the russian
financial system
and putin's ability to wage destruction
this will solidify the complete
isolation of the russian financial
sector from the global system
third
we're banning three big russian
state-owned broadcasters from our
airwaves
they will not be allowed to distribute
their content anymore in the european
union in whatever shape or form
be it on cable via satellite on the
internet or via smartphone apps
we have identified these tv channels as
mouthpieces
that amplify putin's lies and
propaganda aggressively
and we should not give them a stage
anymore to spread these lies
fourth
the kremlin relies on accountants
consultants and spin doctors from europe
and this will now stop
we're banning those services from being
provided in russian to russian companies
and my final point number five
on sanctions is oil
when the leaders met in versailles they
agreed to phase out our dependency on
russian fossil fuels
in the last sanctioned package as you
know we started with coal
today we are addressing our dependency
on russian oil and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil but we simply
have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
this will be
this will be a complete import ban on
all russian oil seaborn and pipeline
crude and refined
we will make sure that we phase out
russian oil in an orderly fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful
that we minimize the impact on the
global market
and this is why we will phase out
russian supply of crude oil within six
months
and refine products by the end of the
year
thus we maximize the pressure pressure
on russia
while at the same time and this is
important we minimize the collateral
damage to us and our partners around the
globe because to help ukraine
we have to make sure that our economy
remains strong
honourable members
with all these steps we are depriving
the russian economy from its ability to
diversify and to modernize
putin wanted to wipe out ukraine from
the map
and he will clearly not succeed on the
contrary
ukraine has risen in bravery and in
unity
and it is his own country russia that
putin is sinking
honourable members
we want ukraine to win this war
but we also want to set the condition
for ukraine's success in the aftermath
of the war
and this is my second point relief and
reconstruction
the first step is immediate relief
this is about short-term economic
support
to help ukraine cope with the fallout of
the war
we have done a lot already let me remind
you our micro financial assistant
package
or the direct support to the ukrainian
budget
in addition we recently proposed to
suspend all import duties on ukrainian
exports to our union for one year
and i'm sure that the european
parliament will put its weight behind
this idea in this proposal
but we all know this is not enough for
the term relief
ukraine's gdp
is expected to fall by 35 to 50 percent
this year alone
and the imf estimates that from may on
ukraine ukraine needs 5 billion euros
per month
plain and simply to keep the country
running so to pay pensions to pay
salaries to provide for basic services
we have to support them but i also know
that we cannot do this alone so i very
much welcome that the united states
announced massive budgetary support and
we as two team europes we have to do our
share too
but then in a second phase
there's the wider reconstruction effort
and you all know that the scale of the
destruction is staggering hospitals and
schools houses roads bridges railroads
theaters factories you just name it so
much has to be rebuilt
of course in the fog of war it is
difficult to come up with a precise
estimate
but economists are talking about several
hundred billion euros
and here honorable members
i think europe has a very special
responsibility towards ukraine
with our support and of course with the
help of the international financial
institutions and other global partners
ukraine can rebuild their country for
the next generation
and this is why today i propose to you
that we start working
on an ambitious recovery package for our
ukrainian friends
if we do it right
this package should bring massive
investments
to meet the needs and the necessary
reforms in parallel
so it should address the existing
weaknesses of the ukrainian economy
and lay the foundation for sustainable
long-term growth
it could set a system of milestones and
targets to make sure that the european
money
truly delivers to the people of ukraine
and is spent in accordance with european
rules
it could help fight corruption we have
to do that it could align the legal
environment with european standards
and radically upgrade ukraine's
productive capacity
and this will bring
the stability and the certainty
that is needed to make ukraine an
attractive destination for foreign
direct investment
and eventually honorable members
it will pave the way
for ukraine's future inside the european
union slava ukrainia long live europe
thank you very much
commission president i now give the
floor to the representatives of the
political groups
starting with the epp group ester de
lange
thank you thank you madam president
mother minister madam uh president of
the european commission
um best colleagues
uh
colleagues it's the fourth of may today
and in the netherlands that means at
eight o'clock this evening we all
stay still
for two minutes the country
falls silent and thinks of the victims
of the second world war and all of those
who died during peace missions
and operations and on a day uh like
today it seems a little bit strange to
be talking here about the economic
consequences of the war here in europe
it is uh there is now war on our
consequent and the consequences here in
the eu
are affected by what's happening in
ukraine
and should remain not on the economic
consequences here but on the
consequences in ukraine and how to help
them against putin's barbaric war and
this is why i'm very grateful to the
commission that they will announce their
sixth sanctions package today and for
the words that the commission has spoken
about the reconstruction and the help to
ukraine but that being said we should
also talk about the social economic
consequences here and our capacity to
act
because as a european union unity
is our strongest weapon against this war
and if we want to sustain this unity we
also need to address the consequences
here
i think madam president of the
commission for the epp we badly need an
analysis of the commutative effect
of
the war the rising energy prices the
shortages in raw materials new
legislation on the table the impact that
has
on companies and on citizens within the
eu we need to address the consequences
also on families some of them not even
turning on their heating because they
can no longer uh do so and this is why
of course we're working
uh to address these consequences um in
uh the fund that is proposed and finally
we need to work to address the the
consequences on companies and on
industries and for the epp that means a
diversification strategy
for raw materials i think which is badly
needed the necessary investment for the
roll out of renewable energy and finally
let's be very honest we are asking a lot
from our industries and don't get me
wrong the epp wants to achieve the
objectives of the fit for 55 package and
the climate law but we may have to we
may have to look at a legislative
embargo for new legislation to make sure
that we're not burdening certain
industries that are suffering badly with
the cumulative effect of higher prices
the ambitious fit for 55 package and for
example let me mention one piece of
legislation new reach at the same time
let's be honest
we stand ready to work with you but
let's do it in a smart way thank you
very much
thank you miss
delanger
and now on behalf of the smd group i
invite iracia garcia perez to take the
floor
gracias president
thank you president
let's be frank ladies and gentlemen we
are at war the european union is
supporting ukraine as a country that has
been aggressed with all means available
sanctions arms help to refugees and
diplomacy
without the
courage of the ukrainian people and the
support of the european union and our
allies ukraine would not have been able
to withstand the criminal aggression of
putin nor frustrated his plans for a
rapid victory
now we're going to see a decisive battle
in donbass and we need to continue
the next step has to
be cutting off gas and oil as the
president of the commission said and
this is in line with the
with what the parliament had already
said
at the same time we have to work on a
strategy
to deconnect ourselves from this gas
building rega reclassification plants
and
we have to see
alternative suppliers and quickly
accelerate uh renewables
i think now more than ever we need to
make progress
in our policies to fight climate change
because these are the ones which clearly
show our shortcomings as a european
union
beating putin does not mean
leaving those countries that are most
affected by their high level of
dependency on russian gas and oil to
their fate i'm aware that some countries
that are going to be much more affected
by these decisions than others
beating potent means resisting
strengthening our determination and um
reacting together
faced with this crucial moment in
history without of course forgetting the
asymmetrical effects of this crisis i
understand therefore that it's necessary
to stand by the principle of solidarity
and to use all means available to do
this beating putin also means
putting an end to first and second level
european union citizens we have to
incorporate romania and bulgaria into
schengen and ensure that we protect our
values
we have to implement the principle
of the fundamental principle of the
european union which is solidarity
supporting refugees it's not possible
that on the one hand we say thank you to
these countries for the way that they're
handling refugees but at the other hand
we're not able to say that they have the
same rights as all other countries when
they meet all of the criteria that are
necessary to be part of the schengen
zone
and this is particularly what i want to
draw council's attention to our citizens
are aware of the tragedy that is being
lived at the moment and now it's the
commission that has to be up to the
financial challenge that we're going to
see and they have to make all means
available we need a
big urgent economic plan
which will
put a break on rising poverty inequality
and unemployment and loss of purchasing
power as a consequence of the rampant
inflation that has been caused by um the
rising costs of fuel and food
it's unacceptable that while the big
energy companies are making huge profits
and um
that seem to be falling from the sky
it's the most vulnerable people who are
paying for the consequences of this war
this money
is going into the pockets of some people
but it's leading to the suffering of
other families that today can't pay
their heating bill
and they're struggling to get to the end
of the month
and so we have to do something here we
can't repeat the errors of the past
whereby
we make cuts in the middle of a crisis
we have to extend the escape clause and
the stability and growth path
we have to invest in new technologies
social justice and a
more secure future where we are free of
our dependence on coal
if the european union wants to be an
international leader um against
autocracy then we have to ensure that we
protect the most vulnerable people
against people
against the consequences of putin from
africa to closer to home
if uh
moldova wants to be an independent state
and part of this free zone then they
have to have our financial and military
commitment uh this is a historic moment
we have coming to rebuild and construct
peace in europe
on our borders however there can be no
peace without justice because it's the
humiliated and the wronged as uh
dostoyevsky reminds us who
require uh respite from their suffering
who require justice the only way to
ensure that we have proper peace is to
defeat putin and to see victory for
liberty and democracy in ukraine this
needs unity from us and for us to make
sacrifices in 2012 we were able to do
this to protect the euro and we stood
firm in 2020 against the pandemic and in
2022 we will stand firm to preserve
peace and democracy thank you thank you
very much miss garcia perez next on
behalf of the renew group luis garricano
thanks malam president it's good to see
that i'm the fifth speaker and the first
man so that's it that's a good
um
so
um
just a
quick a quick few reactions to your to
your proposals
from the line i was i was very happy to
hear about the this rrf2 uh this
recovery reconstruction fund using the
lessons from what we learned for ukraine
that's that's good news it there was no
no news on how to finance it so i hope
that's that's coming um also i think
that spending on reconstruction is very
good but as you very well said there are
very urgent funding needs and we need to
see how we're going to address them and
third you mentioned the embargo on oil
this parliament is really happy to hear
that and congratulations and that's
that's great news that we are moving on
the old embargo but as you know this is
far sure of what's short of what this
parliament wants we actually asked a
month ago for a full embargo on gas and
oil while the debate goes on
the
eu has sent to russia 50 billion euros
since the start of the year 52 billion
today
and by the time we get all this oil
embargo set etc
putin will have received over 100
billion euros more in revenues
we are now in the worst of all worlds
consumers are paying the higher prices
but these high prices are sufficiently
high
that putin gets higher revenues than
before more than compensated for the
loss of volume
and some say nothing else can be done
and this is false
there is a clear solution which will
collapse russian revenue incentivize
substitution protect consumers and even
madame from the line increase eu
resources
what is this miracle
it is the oldest trick in the book a
tariff
a tariff on russian energy would allow
us to shift some of the extra revenues
from higher gas and oil prices to us the
consumers from the russian producers
with a tariff the price that european
consumers pay will go up a little bit
some consumers will continue consuming
some of them will stop it depends on how
much need they have but the gap between
the price that the consumers pay and
what the russians receive is actually
the revenue from the tariff that would
flow to the european taxpayers the
european union and that could be given
back to europeans to compensate for the
high guys price for the higher gas
prices and the suppliers would be the
one facing the trouble since a lower
quantity
is going to be supplied it will be
supplied at a lower price don't forget
the russian
oil and gas suppliers are desperately
dependent on european purchases between
us and our allies we purchase 80 of the
oil and gas and they will be willing to
supply at the lower prices that the
tariff will involve for them why first
the eu and us are buying 80 of the
fossil fuel exports and the
infrastructure bottlenecks
make it very hard to shift those exports
to asia second
production costs are low at 20
a barrel so they will actually have to
accept those lower revenues and rather
than shutting down the wells
in short a tariff would allow us to
shift russian revenues to the european
union consumers all while accelerating
an end to european dependency on the
moscow's fuels
even if a high tariff comes with the
cost for the european union it is more
efficient way to stop putting than any
of the other sanctions that we already
have in place before the embargo comes
in as fast as possible let's do it now
it must be a new tool in our armor and
hands in our capacity to act thank you
thank you very much mr garikano i now
give the floor on behalf of the green
group to sarah mathieu
thank you chair
madame leminis commission president
we've condemned the horrible and
unjustified invasion in ukraine by the
russian military forces many times
before
and the european union was highly united
in its response severe actions were
implemented
and just last plenary this parliament
demanded an embargo on all russian
fossil fuels including gas
however these sanctions will not only
harm the russian economy they will also
affect the lives of european citizens
with a direct impact on their homes
their jobs their wallets and this could
lead to more social inequality to a rise
of unemployment and an increase in
energy poverty
we need to protect our citizens and
specifically those at risk of falling
into poverty people that are afraid of
not being able to heat their homes next
winter
we need a strong social response to
their fears
the eu has the choice to leave no one
behind
to mitigate the rise in energy costs
to ensure decent and affordable housing
for all
the eu has the choice to protect workers
on the labor market against unemployment
the eu has the choice to ensure that
climate transition is a fair transition
where industry pays its fair share
we need minimum wages minimum income
protection for all and a european
unemployment scheme colleagues we have
the possibility to protect our citizens
against the hardships of war well now is
the time to act thank you thank you very
much miss mathieu
next on behalf of the id group jordan
bardella
thank you very much president president
of the commission for uh two months the
horror of war is striking our continent
uh uh on our doorstep we see these
events and we want to demonstrate
solidarity faced with the atrocities and
war crimes
we see the collateral economic damage
and
we see
uh that uh
the um those with the least are being
hit the hardest
uh and are struggling to feed themselves
or heat their homes and uh becoming more
and more anxious
it's really a question about our
dependencies that on imported fossil
fuels that we
and also agricultural products which are
being produced uh
far from home
this teaches us the lesson of history
sovereignty is the price of liberty and
so we need to strengthen our energy
autonomy
by supporting uh
nuclear energy which is the cleanest
most carbon neutral energy we have at
the moment and stop
giving in to the pressure from the
greens
and
it is also our duty to uh
regain our food sovereignty on the basis
of fair trade
and we need to encourage local
production and all of this will protect
our agriculture and uh
all of this is uh
undermined by the farm to fork strategy
of the commission which condemns our
farmers to ruin and we calls for urgent
measures for purchasing power of our
citizens we have to uh
reduce uh
taxes on coal
we is on fuel
and we see that energy sanctions being
taken by europe have undermined our uh
purchasing power while enriching rusty
the high rates uh
and uh we are exporting they are
benefiting from the exports of raw
materials and uh
the
uh
there was a persian of uh
a lada in russia for a notional amount
and this is undermining french
governments to make it possible for
russia to nationalize them um free of
charge
and so we need to look at gas and oil uh
and we need to sanction those who are
benefiting from what and we need to um
move away from dependency we need to
follow a simple principle of the
sanctions that need to punish putin and
not to hit the wallet of european
citizens or companies and i would ask
you to think of them thank you
merci next on behalf of the ecr group
rafael
thank you president minister
president of the commission
well i've listened with a great deal of
attention to
the
speeches this morning and i think it's
very useful and important that we hold
this debate this morning
to try and find immediate solutions to
this conflict
there's no doubt that the path that has
been taken so far is one that we need to
pursue with a decisiveness
because the
packet of sanctions that have been put
forward is clearly a decisive element
that we need to work on to ensure that
we get results
but a sanctions package
is also fundamental to the decisions
that have to be taken in europe
these measures are not incredibly
popular across our continent because
they could lead to serious consequences
of course the long-term objective of
reconstruction in ukraine is fundamental
and the commission is absolutely right
to have its eye on this but at the
moment we have to face
the situation before us
europe's exports in february in march is
six percent down
we need a strong response
a compensation fund well we saw that
that one was used for brexit well we
could have a similar solution here
sanctions do not affect all countries in
the same manner there are some countries
that face more serious consequences than
others
second issue
it comes to the structural choices as mr
de langan raised
fifa 55.
can you imagine that we won't be
changing anything compared to what we
envisioned before the war well the war
is an event that should
allow and make us think about the
commission's choices
and the choices of the european
institutions well i think that that is
the case
excessively ambitious targets
that we find within fit for 55
are an important aspect that we need to
think about and adapt
and another
concrete proposal
we need a response to the big economic
issues we face this stability and growth
pact for example this has been put off
for later there's no decision at the
moment but it's going to be important
when it comes to taking the necessary
measures
and this is an issue that we raised
article 21 of the rrf states that in
exceptional circumstances this
instrument
which
carries important resources with it can
be modified to respond to events well
this is an article that was enshrined in
the regulation that says that we may
need to change national plans
in response to new needs
well i think this is exactly the kind of
circumstances that the article was uh
written for
that we do need to be able to envisage a
change of direction
and i'd like to close with one final
comment
we need
to be effective with count with
sanctions and for that there are two
aspects are required
we need a unified response to gas if
there is
any one who wants to take their own
approach that will weaken the overall
approach group martin sherdon
thank you president
in train stations in europe um
people are voluntarily welcoming
refugees from ukraine
providing them with protection uh a
whole millions are looking for jobs and
um
homes
at the moment in ukraine uh there's um
harvests which are being uh threatened
uh
ex
are blocked there's no
uh sunflower oil anymore uh butter
prices have been increased by forty four
percent
for vegetables up to thirty percent uh
food prices in in the eu are exploding
and the
the supply chains are saying that there
could be a cr worldwide crisis
and a hunger
and energy prices uh
have
gone through the ceiling and uh
36
million people in the eu are not able to
heat appropriately those are figures
from the commission
and following the pandemic uh the
uh
war
shows that there are problems with
energy supplies all of this is leading
uh to uh for explosion of prices
increasing inflation we've got food
prices increasing energy prices
increasing and uh
inflation is eating up wages and
pensions and so for that reason we need
an energy price cap so that we can fight
against increasing energy prices we need
a european effort at the moment to help
the poorest households and protect them
against uh inflation energy poverty and
hunger and for for that we we need uh
attacks on
armaments
companies on energy producers
because
their
profits are increasing and also large
companies like um amazon and good and
google benefited hugely from the panel
and that would be a first step to
mitigate some of the social consequences
and that would release fronts that are
coming from production
and that would make it possible
to support those fleeing war it is
true that we need to work towards
independence from a gas
and oil from russia
i think we need to make sure that these
monies go into a
socially fair energy
and that's not just a question of
russian gas and oil it's a gas
and oil from any source
and
some of the uh sanctions which have been
passed uh are
not helping the homes
yachts and cars of the oligarchs
need to be kept in the same condition
and so now european taxpayers are paying
to maintain these frozen assets
i think that's absurd
they need to be expropriated and used
for other purposes
and
all of the uh benefits from that
would have to go to the benefit of
refugees and not to the maintenance of
yachts of oligarchs and now on behalf of
the non-attached members martin guillen
thank you madam president my colleagues
president from the line there is a broad
consensus here and in other eu
institutions that economic sanctions on
russia are the most effective way of
pressurizing russia to stop its
aggression in the ukraine
the speed the efficiency and accuracy of
the sanctions proposed by the commission
need to be commended
especially its efforts to create an
unprecedented unity among member states
it is unfortunate that it took such a
disaster to realize the unhealthy
dependence of our continent on russian
energy supplies
and start discussions about a unified
energy market based on diversified
energy resources and solidarity among
member states in the past weeks russia
has demonstrated that it's ready to use
energy as a strategic weapon to further
its aggressive geopolitical objectives
it must be clear by now that russia in
the long term is an unreliable partner
for supplying energy to the eu
therefore i would like to ask the
commission not only to focus on fossil
fuels when it comes to sanctions but
also target nuclear energy
nuclear deals struck by russian rosatom
with
various governments of various member
states must be phased out
finland showed the way by terminating
the fenovoyma deal with rosatom that
supplied a nuclear reactor
was the financial backer of the project
and the main shareholder it's time that
hungary follows suit and terminates its
equally controversial
pakistan the commission would be right
in its next sanction package to ban
every russian nuclear deal on the
continent thank you
thank you very much our next speaker is
mr secret maurizan
thank you mr president president fondele
and dear colleagues we have all seen
russia is a threat for the security of
the european union and will remain a
threat for us for the foreseeable future
this is why we can only live in safety
and stability within the borders of the
european union if we are surrounded in
our immediate neighborhood by countries
who are safe and stable helping ukraine
clearly means also helping ourselves
this is why the line needs to be
continue supporting ukraine sanctioning
the russian federation president
thunderline we are welcoming the new
package of sanctions which you presented
to us which you are putting forward we
as a parliament have demanded an
immediate ban on imports of russian oil
gas coal and nuclear fuel this is why as
the commission will be implementing the
ban on russian oil it has to be
implemented it has to take effect as
soon as possible and in a way in which
it does not allow for any loopholes and
special treatments for member states for
for companies because this would
endanger the unity of the european union
keeping our unity as we are also
implementing this ban will be important
firstly secondly as we reduce our
dependency on russian fossil fuels we
should not create dependencies on any
other single route of transport single
source of energy or supplying supplying
country
we are seeing that any vulnerability any
weakness costs in times of crisis what
should we do within the european union
because the title of the debate is
social and economic consequences for the
european union firstly we should use the
existing tools which we have to
strengthen our economy there is still
money available in the recovery
resilience facility because some member
states have not accessed all of the
loans component we need to work with
member states to see if they need the
money if they will access it and if not
the position of our group of the epp is
to try to use those amounts for large
energy projects transnational
energy projects to interconnect to bring
energy to where it is needed within the
european union if an amendment of the
rof regulation is needed for this we
should do it
next point um
use the decommitted amounts from the
budget 2014 2020 to allow member states
um to
spend the money on where they need it
particularly in helping refugees and
host communities within the borders of
the eu and one last idea which helps
ukraine and helps the european union is
work towards integrating ukraine and the
republic of moldova into the eu single
market as soon as circumstances allows
this will help ukraine to develop by its
own with the cost being more
controllable for us thank you very much
very much
[Music]
and now i give the floor to anus young
areas
thank you chair
and colleagues
the title of the debate is the social
economic consequences
for the eu of the russian war in the
ukraine and of course
the consequences in ukraine are huge
but i think we should also be clear that
the war in ukraine plunges us also in a
new social economic crisis and with
skyrocketing energy prices with deep
diving purchasing power and with
increasing inflation
i fear that the foremost vulnerable will
bear the burden
and the question should be then i think
what route are we going to take
it's our duty
that the stronger shoulders bear the
heaviest burden
while standing up against putin and
standing in solidarity with the ukraine
in this crisis we need to address the
root causes
of the long-term economic and social
imbalances i think it's time to break
the vicious circle
of raising inequalities and privilege
for the super rich
there are many things
to fix
and those who are increasing their
profits exponentially and indecently are
the ones to pay the price first
and therefore we need more than just
an extension of the escape clause
we need a european solution we need
money to accommodate the refugees from
the ukraine
we need support for the citizens and
small businesses
for rising energy prices
um
in my mother minister i think we should
not talk about energy poverty anymore we
are talking about actual poverty
people who cannot pay their bills
anymore and therefore my proposal is to
organize a social summit with the social
partners to tackle the challenges of
increasing inflation
increasing inequalities and its social
consequences
especially
on the living conditions and wages
we need to update the action plan of the
social pillar we need european action
thank you
merci
madame
you are the next one
thank you president
commissioner
madam minister colleagues
every day that passes
we are sending billions of euros to
putin through coal gas and oil purchases
these hundreds of millions allow him to
pay his soldiers and decrease his
military spending
we have to put an end to this war
economy and not feed it further
commissioner
we can't imagine that the
eu can uh
get through this without suffering any
pain and without solidarity
so we need to go further we should be
mutualizing the costs of this war for
our
companies for our citizens if we are
imposing sanctions then we have to
take the necessary consequences at the
european level but that's not all
trying to respond is one thing but
trying to preempt future developments is
another let's take a step back
are we going to continue to beat the
mercy of uh vladimir putin if we had
taken a choice eight years ago when uh
moscow entered crimea wouldn't the story
have been very different today if we had
been stronger if we had got away from
our dependence on
russian hydrocarbons and hydrocarbons in
general i think that would have changed
things significantly that's
incontestable
this invasion and its consequences
are our last warning
so yes we do need to create safe a fund
for our strategic economy in europe we
need to get out of our dependence
by the end of the decade
when we're talking about critical
industries defense
hydrocarbons agricultural inputs
we need to take the necessary
consequences seize our destiny
we have to make europe europe that
protect
time will not forgive us if we don't
merci
excuse me
thank you
our next speaker is mr ernest
thank you chair commission uh council
let me first welcome the the president
wonderland announcement on the vine that
russia all to be included in the new
sanctions package
this report to ukraine needs to go hand
in hand also in supporting our citizens
most affected from the conscious
consequences of war
we are at the doors of possible possibly
the third once in a lifetime deep crisis
that generations of europeans will
suffer the cumulative crisis have led to
devastating social consequences in our
continents
96 million people in the eu are already
at risk of poverty increased
inequalities the return of war in europe
and the existential threat of climate
change is a scary prospect and once
again history knocks at the doors of the
european project
during the pandemic do you learn how to
respond to difficult economic and social
situations after the disastrous years of
the austeritarian lunacy now we need to
show that this willingness to protect
our citizens will be the norm and not
the exception
price inflation in the eu has reached
levels not seen since the 70s but half
we know is directly due to fossil energy
price rises and it is why we need action
on the energy sector it is no time it is
not time in our opinion to restrict or a
commodity of monetary policy which would
have disastrous economic consequences
but to accelerate our energy transition
and it is not time either i'm sorry to
say to postpone or green new deal i mean
climate change does not wait and we know
that our green deal and energy
transition is the best solution to the
crisis that we are having so i cannot
more than disagree with what the epp has
had this morning today in the plenary
we know that we need to accelerate that
energy transition and for that we will
probably need also no financial
instruments to be put in place that is
what that is why we want also to call
for a new energy sovereignty facility to
facilitate member states to accelerate
that transition we know that politically
this is difficult
putting in place the rrf was a difficult
process but we need to be ambitions and
i'm sure that we will be able to do that
again thank you so much
thank you
our next speaker is mr
jack madison
thank you so much mr president mr
commissioner uh
councillor um first of all i was
checking uh yesterday morning about the
statistic that how much have you paid
to russia for the gas and oil and for
the coal
and the first two months after the war
the biggest
buyer
and the payer for russia is of course
germany the second one is italy the
third one is turkey and the fourth one
is netherlands and if i compared the
prices what we paid i mean we as a
europeans what we paid to russia for the
gas and oil it was three times higher
amount of money than it was exactly
on the same time in last year
and of course the germans and others who
are buying the gas from russia they're
saying it's the market price
but the problem today now what we have
is
that
we as europeans are paying three times
more money to russia
and we are saying that well it's a
market price but it's not true
the russians are saying you have to pay
this amount of money for the gas
otherwise we will not sell it
and we
are not the smartest ones and we are
paying this money so it means that every
day
we are paying hundreds of millions of
euros to russia to have the energy
resources
and they are using this money for the
military and for the war machine against
ukraine maybe tomorrow against moldova
maybe in few days against baltic states
or i guess finland
so
what is my point
we have now in the situation
and now the summer is coming so it's the
good time but in september october
november when the winter is coming
we will be again in the situation where
we are paying
many many times more money for the
resources for the energy
from russia to have
a warm house to have functioning
technology to have functioning
businesses and that's why today the
germans and australians and also
hungarians unfortunately have to say
unfortunately they are saying that no we
can't stop now
the import
for the energy from russia
but we have to think now how to survive
next winter because otherwise we'll be
screwed and otherwise we are still
paying more and more money three times
more than last year to russia and this
money will be used for the new
occupations
for the new explanations
and that's the fault of the european
energy policy we have to learn from the
mistakes what we have done
and look for the next winter thanks so
much
thank you
thank you
the next speaker will be mrs ebayata
sidlow
two minutes 30.
president
minister
dia call ladies and gentlemen
human life
human life cannot be
quantified
but money is
important to support
ukraine
and to make sure that this
period
the faster we stop
we
will
be able to ensure
peace in ukraine we need to take
decisive steps and
make sure that there is solidarity
it's
good that the sixth package is being
introduced a little bit too late but
hopefully it's going to be
effective and hopefully
uh next time
in strasbourg we will be able to say
that this
package is effective because so far
one may have an impression
that decisions
were being made but that they were not
being implemented to stop putin we must
be decisive
and we
must be consistent and courageous today
we need
that courage
we should not be afraid to stop putting
and we should not be afraid to say
enough is enough
we must draw our conclusions
um
for what we have neglected in the union
in the past
and one more thing um
ukrainian refugees
require help and the member states that
support refugees need funds
we cannot quantify human life but to
support
the refugees we need funds
and therefore
similarly as in the past we need to
create a special fund that will help the
member states that are helping ukraine
thank you
um
the next speaker will be mr nikolai
williamson
the war in ukraine is horrific
we must do everything in our power to
stop it
to help the ukrainians
it is important that the eu implement
sanctions but they're clearly not tough
enough
to make putin pull back his troops
therefore we need to increase the
pressure
we must stop the imports of russian oil
and gas
we need to hit putin and the oligarchs
where it hurts
the war and solidarity with ukraine
will also affect our own economy
therefore it is vital
that we protect our low-income families
this is also part of our fight against
putin because the broader shoulders of
course need to carry the
heaviest loads
it is tragic that so many families are
struggling to make ends meet and need to
choose between food or heating
that's not the way it should be in the
eu in 2022
nobody should starve or be forced to
leave their home
we need to protect the weakest in our
society it is vital if we are to stand
together against putin
let us tax the excessive abnormal
profits
let's stop the speculation in increasing
food energy and raw material prices let
us help the ukrainian refugees
the ukrainian refugees are welcome in
the eu
and like all other refugees they deserve
to be treated well also by the labor
market
therefore we need to make clear demands
on the employers so that our ukrainian
friends are not paid below normal levels
or misused in other ways
therefore we need clear social demands
for payouts on eu funds and our
taxpayers money should not go to
companies that do not stick to
collective agreements or who hide in tax
havens
eu money should not go to greedy
employers or rich people who let down
the community dear colleagues let's
instead stand together against putin
let's protect low-income families and
let's stand in solidarity
in this terrible war thank you
thank you
thank you
and now the next speaker will be mr
ludwig nidomier
thank you mr president dear colleagues
dear guests
a cruel illegal and irresponsible attack
of putin russia
on ukraine has killed so far thousands
of people
brought full-scale wall to europe
territory
and destroyed remaining naive trust to a
rule-based relationship with russia
economic and social implications are
only part of this as esther has
mentioned in in her speech but this is
the part that shouldn't be neglected we
are dealing with difficult combination
of high inflation that will be boosted
by the war
the
implication
for some member states of high inflow of
refugees
as well as disruption of the businesses
for firms that had ties with russia or
ukraine
lack of public confidence is only
completing the picture
most of the economic forecasts are still
assuming very moderate impact on
economic growth in the magnitude just
slightly above one percent
this is something that we can deal about
but these conditions these assumptions
are based on the condition that there is
no disruption of energy supply to europe
we should also have in mind that the
impact is not equally spread
anyway we must take some policy action
this should be fact-based but should be
effective and quick
first we must get ready for interruption
of the gas supply
every day moscow can decide to cut the
supply better preparation means that the
damaging cost will be lower the secondly
i guess it's economically rational to
react with domestic social and economic
policy especially on high energy prices
but at the same time uh instead of
building temporary support permanent
support mechanism we should speed up
introduction of renewables and energy
efficiency
we must make sure that we reduce the red
tapes and any other measures that are
slowing down the economy
more economic growth means also lower
unemployment and smaller problems of the
fiscal policy last not least we must
redirect eu funds to deal with the
current challenges and use the sources
that we have effectively thank you
thank you
mr jonas fernandez floyd
good morning thank you president
commission
council
i'd like to start this debate by
congratulating the european commission
for the new package that they presented
this morning
and of course for the leadership that
they've shown in taking decisions to
help ukraine
and to
undermine the intentions of putin
we hope that council will maintain the
unity that we've seen in past months
there have been some uh proposals which
haven't seen
support
but we want to minimize the probability
of problems within the council
the debate on the
effects within the european union is a
complex one
there are social aspects
as we have heard
we have to take in these millions of
refugees who have come to europe and at
the same time there are economic
consequences that are not easy to tackle
higher
inflation
and some of the growth forecasts are
rather difficult so in the spirit of
consensus that we have in this
parliament we have to keep in mind that
the vast majority of measures that have
been taken so far with by member states
for example uh
have been taken by uh member states for
example if you look at my country we see
that the right doesn't want to support
the government at this very difficult
time
often politics haven't responded in a
rapid uh
time to the increase in
inflation
um we have to look at what's happening
in the united states for example and we
have to also
remember that we have the possibility to
open up
new tools to ensure that we can respond
economically and to show solidarity
uh including
with the
sanctions that we will support jointly
thank you
[Music]
thank you chair dear commissioner
mr clinton
we have spent the past two years talking
about how we emerge
how to emerge from the kovid 19 crisis
stronger
we have spent
two months of war in ukraine doing the
same
a crisis has this grim gift of providing
ample supplies of one of the most
elusive and valuable resource europe
needs the political will to embrace
change and to do the things that need to
be done
i upload the continuation of the
sanctions
but we are still far away from the
parliament position
we still need ambitious tools
and the instruments to move forward in
the pandemic we have created the rf and
other funds and measures that show
solidarity that kept our businesses
sometimes barely afloat and helped our
citizens
now in two months we have moved defense
supplies of an unprecedented scale
and opened our countries to many
more millions of ukrainian refugees that
we had seen during the 2015 refugee
crisis
we do have right now a momentum of
political will to reinforce our capacity
to act for all europeans ukrainians
included
as they firmly belong in europe by
culture values geography and now by
bravery and commitment
i think
it is time indeed to use the rrf at its
full potential to use all the resources
to use all the lessons learned and the
solutions for the member states and this
is part of the response
but at the same time we should focus
indeed and i was really pleased to hear
today
that there is a discussion about the
recovery plan from ukraine
and for that we need indeed to use the
lessons learned from the rf that are
indeed valuable
the reward will never be the same again
and russia with putin in charge will
never again be a partner for europe so
there is no more status law to return to
and we need to create a new normal one
with reinforced financial tools that
will ensure no european is left behind
in the aftermath of putin's war and
ukraine and moldova as well get welcome
they need from you and that we emerge
once again stronger together thank you
[Applause]
for our colleague
madam terry rydenke you're the next
speaker
thank you chad dear colleagues dear
commissioner dear pres dear minister the
president is right european history will
be written in ukraine that is why our
support for a free european democracy
against the brutal russian aggression is
paramount right now and it is our
historic responsibility to do everything
possible to show this solidarity
including hard and far-reaching
sanctions and i'm happy to hear that a
deal has been reached on a ban of
russian oil it is an important next step
but it is certainly not the last one
that we will need and while this
parliament strongly supports the
sanctions we also already see the
negative consequences this war has for
europe
after years of pandemic we see the
economic struggle of many households in
the european union
and our reaction to the pandemic despite
some challenges in the beginning was
based on one of our strongest assets
solidarity with the next generation eu
fund we manage to show that we can stand
together in times of crisis
and the same and probably more is needed
now
because we all know what putin is trying
to do he's trying to divide us to play
member state against member state and to
count that the social hardship that we
will face will dry out our firm support
for ukraine
putin is trying to divide europe to
divide our societies he's counting on
our inability to manage this great
challenge together
we cannot colleagues and we will not let
him succeed in this
let us show that we will face this
challenge together the east and the west
of europe the north and the south let us
show that all that he's succeeding in
will be to revive the european social
model the promise of a european union
where nobody will be left behind
for that we will need joint efforts
investments a solidarity fund to balance
out the social inequality and we will
have to proceed in creating a real
social safety net on the european level
by finally introducing a european
minimum wage closing the gender pay gap
and yes also a european minimum income
this continent is weakest when it's
divided and strongest when it is united
let us be united against poutine thank
you very much
thank you
our next speaker is michael campbell
two minutes 30.
[Music]
thank you president thank you
commissioner for being here with us
the uh consequences on the social and
economic fabric of european countries
are of course significant however the
positive side is that we are all united
we're supporting the sanctions and the
new package
this is correct and it is yielding
results
of course it has having consequences in
terms of costs to our system
and our business model
but we need to move forward
because it's an important strategy
the unity that we've demonstrated here
is important however it shouldn't
prevent us from properly analyzing the
situation that is arising including in
terms of the mistakes that we've made in
the past
we have arrived at this dependence on
russia
including just a few weeks before the
outbreak of war
there were some people here who were
supporting projects like nordstrom 2.
uh so
we uh have projects that we need to look
at for this but of course they will take
time to implement
we've seen problems for example such as
uh storing energy resources for the next
winter we also have to look at the
question of payments in rubles or euro
because business needs clarity
so
i think it would be helpful if the
commission could clarify some of these
points
and we're seeing also tensions are
rising on the market there's uh
inflation purchasing power for families
as colleagues have said is also becoming
a problem
at the heart of it what's the question
here is the competitiveness of our
system
the
agro
food sector is already experiencing
consequences and our social
systems risk paying very dearly for this
as well as our
colleagues uh politicians at national
and regional level
as a number of colleagues have already
said however we shouldn't make the
mistake
with the um stability and growth pack
going back to the mistaken standards
that uh
we did in the past and uh we should
continue to grow as we have over the
last 20 years and also the fit for 55
packages leading to
costs for business
often enormous costs and these were um
put together for a pre-pandemic europe
imagine how unsuitable they are for
europe at war
thank you very much
and economic consequence of the
ukrainian war are huge
uh uh that is clear particularly given
that we've got uh high inflation
and uh but uh the greatest challenge is
not because of the uh it's the
policy of the ecb
which has been um
feeding money into the system
and uh we have also crippled our economy
with lockdowns and then there's the
green deal
from the eu which is leading to an
inflation and increasing the cost of
energy and uh food but through
the war energy prices have gone even
higher and
this is a fundamental factor in the
economy and part of our welfare i think
it is a clear that russia attacked uh
ukraine and i understand very well why
we want to do something
to protest against that uh
i have pleaded for uh eu union against
russian but we have to make sure
the sanctions are working are they
having the desired effect on russia
and
now we're going to go further with a new
round of energy sanction
not just
because of the rising energy prices um
it
rusty is increasing the prices have
increased
as a result
of a sanction and the world is bigger
than the eu
and uh
if we're importing gas uh there's more
strain on the economy and uh people uh
uh we we need to stop shooting ourselves
in the foot it is a time
for uh
uh politicians to look at the welfare of
our citizens and i just want to say uh
that
russia is getting rich and uh europe is
uh moving into poverty and we need to
have uh
a solution we need to get people around
the negotiating table and that needs
efforts by ukraine and the eu thank you
thank you very much next speaker is mrs
lydia pereira
mr president fellow europeans
war is at our gates
europeans are suffering with fuel prices
on the rise
with food prices particularly bread and
other essentials going through the roof
in fact many europeans are facing
difficulties to which we cannot turn our
faces in denial
but we need to face the social and
economic consequences of this war
not only inside the eu but also in
ukraine
we must not just walk or talk the talk
we must to do the walk the talk the walk
we must reinforce our capacity to walk
the walk not just for today but also for
tomorrow
we must not settle for a few good
speeches and beautiful words and loads
of indignity in social media
we must do what we can do as soon as we
can to make sure that something like
this does not happen again
we need a legal
freeze and sees instrument we need to
make russia pay for war reparations to
ukraine and we need that money we need
to help creating an adequate recovery
plan to rebuild ukraine's infrastructure
and relaunch ukraine's economy
we can be divided into many things and
we frequently are
after all debates and discussion are
what a parliament is about
but dear friends
we cannot be divided about defending
europe from autocratic regimes
we shall not be divided about responding
to other countries blackmailing us
and we will not be divided about putting
european security solidarity and
friendship above anything else
long leave europe
and long live freedom thank you
thank you
thank you the next speaker will be pedro
marcus
madame minister
vice president of the commission
the barbarian war
the barbarous war between russia and
ukraine
calls for us to give all our solidarity
to the ukrainians now and in the future
and with its people
now we need sanctions that weakened the
regime and the russian economy reducing
their capacity to feed the war machine
but they also have an impact on europe
and our citizens it's a price that we're
ready to pay
in
for peace and for freedom today the
peace and freedom of the ukrainians but
if we do nothing it will be ours at
stake
now
in many cases
we have not gone as far as the european
parliament would have liked but today we
have an oil embargo which will affect
the putin regime seriously we've also
got a clear message to pass on to the
commission and to the other european
institutions in the council
our capacity
to stay united in our response to
russian aggression is also going to
depend on whether we're able to manage
the economic and social consequences
here in europe and as sanctions against
russia increase in intensity counter
sanctions and energy prices in europe
are going to affect our economy and our
citizens we have to maintain european
unity that has been of great value in
our response to russia's aggression but
now we need to support europe citizens
and companies there have been lots of
good ideas presented here some good ones
some less good ones
but when it comes to the european
response we need to move strongly in
favor of renewable energies we need to
support the companies that are affected
by high energy prices but not
the energy multinationals that are
making obscene profits
they need to be taxed and we need to
support citizens who are suffering
energy poverty and the effects of energy
policy
and we'd like need to support all of
those who are helping the refugees are
coming our way
that means defending europe defending
ukraine and defending europe's peoples
thank you
thank you
thank you very much our next speaker is
vice president nicola beer
president
minister
uh eu is finally moving that we and
finally have an oil embargo in sight we
europeans need to take this step
it
gives it's no point in just pointing the
finger at russia that's not going to
stop the world following the decisions
on the delivery of weapons the oil
embargo is a long needed
sanction
because
it can undermine russia european
credibility
at the side of ukraine against the
aggressor russia
is then strengthened uh this is
something that i've been missing
but uh
it's not going to be without cost the
energy uh embargo will have an impact on
europe uh despite uh the transition
period there will be impacts on uh
people and uh there will be bottlenecks
between portugal and poland and
we'll talk about replacing um
russian raw materials there will be sex
but we need to be resolute we need to be
ready to pay this price because
colleagues
the european union is able to sustain
these impacts
and mitigate the impact but we need to
remember that there are other regions
other continents that are not able to
bear this burden as easily and don't
have the advantages that we have
but nevertheless we
mustn't deviate from our course and we
shouldn't be affected by threats from
putin we shouldn't feel
undermined by them we can do this
because if we don't want history to
criticize us and uh say uh that it
wasn't
we didn't do enough uh to
eliminate a
war from our vocabulary and
we need to make sure that we provide
every possible support to ukraine they
are fighting for our freedoms let's put
russia in the
cupboards and do it now
your colleague
for our colleague thank you very much
mr munir satori the next speaker
minister uh
ladies and gentlemen colleagues ukraine
is facing the worst time in its history
europe must
uh show solidarity with those who have
been
attacked
to do this and to live up to its own
words europe and the member state also
have to
strengthen their internal social
solidarity we have to be we have to
prevent vladimir putin's war from
creating
social discord within the eu
europeans are facing increasing
energy pressure and inflation
the right to housing
as well as the right to food must be
guaranteed we have the means to do that
so we have to mobilize the funds that
are necessary to allow people to live
this crisis
should bring the european union to
question and to change its social
policies to protect the most vulnerable
we have to act in a united manner
against the consequences of this crisis
on the um
and its impact on the social uh arena
and unemployment
and so this is why i call upon the
french presidency of the council to show
how ambitious it is
when it comes to the draft directive on
the minimum wage that is currently being
negotiated a minimum wage has to ensure
decent living standards for all workers
i also
call for a joint initiative to ensure a
minimum income
after covert after years of increasing
uh precarity this
uh war should bring us to believe all
the more in our union and uh
our europe we have to act in a practical
manner to strengthen our social policies
thank you
[Applause]
tank
thank you very much the next speaker is
ivan stephanich
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
colleagues for a third month in a row
brave ukrainians are facing criminal
russian aggression and are defending
freedom not only in their homeland but
throughout europe i had the opportunity
a few weeks ago
to visit kiev visit europe and butcher
after the russian invasion i saw all the
horrors of the russian crimes
for instance in butcher there is not a
single military
facility and yet russian aggressors have
been attacking civilians from the first
day of the aggression i saw mass graves
also
bombed houses
burned cars
i saw toys in front of
damaged houses
these are pictures that are
unforgettable
and also it's absurd that the war
criminal putin is honoring these war
criminals for their acts what russians
see terrorism all normal people see as a
primitive crime and crimes should not be
honored they should be punished i
therefore welcome the penalties
for these criminals and also
i welcome the new sanctions package um
i also welcome
the inclusion of the
russian disinformation channel in the
new sanctioned package for years we've
been inactive against russian propaganda
it's high time for us to act now but we
need to go even further in order to
protect life in europe we need to
diversify europe let's not be afraid
let's cut off
our dependence on russian energy some
countries are very dependent including
my country slovakia i therefore
understand all the worries but the
solution is in finding common approach
in building a common market
in energy
in
joint purchasing there are solutions so
we need to protect freedom we need to
protect human life and dignity
just
as christian democrats have done in
europe
it is all the more valuable today
we need to see
their act as an example as a role model
by helping ukrainians we will help
ourselves the human life has more value
than any money in the world
[Applause]
the next speaker is mrs
helsi katainen
thank you president
commissioner
russian war of aggression to ukraine is
for europe also makes maybe the biggest
ordeal and tests is testing us we have
been created to make peace and now it's
been disrupted in the most worst
possible way way since the second world
war a war is rating in europe and russia
wants to disunite us and the union and
the largest
latest example of this is turning off
the gas taps in bulgaria and poland i
want to appeal to all decision makers
look at the long line of history and
make an end of our dependency on russian
energy
this will have economic consequences and
challenges but morally we have to be
strong enough to bear the consequences
we cannot accept this innovation
bloodshed and bombings of children's
hospitals the eu must be able to be
united and stay united and have
uni
united decisions the the wars
consequences economic and social ones
hit us all more than 5 million
ukrainians have lost their homes and the
eu must be able to assist and help them
the rise in energy prices
affects the food market
commissioner timmerman's estimates that
in the eu there is not there will be no
food crisis are
impossible to understand the best
medicine and way to take to deal with
this crisis
is to secure the position of food
providers and energy suppliers we have
to speed up climate action but be more
rational in because we are producing the
cleanest food in europe and
emission-free energy
now we can mitigate these social losses
mutual debt however is not the road
that our citizens in europe want to go
instead of this we can make use of the
pandemic recovery package because a lot
of those funds are still unused thank
you
mr yan albrecht the floor is yours
president commissioner minister
today we are talking about the social
and economic consequences for the eu but
let's not talk about uh what the
consequences will be but what they may
be
and when we talk about this we should
think about what we are going to do as
the eu in order to reduce negative
consequences as much as possible
what are we going to do what steps are
we going to take
we welcome the next
package of sanctions but we must start
thinking about
how the eu will continue functioning how
it will be organized how it will be
managed and how it will be financed
i am the rapporteur
responsible for the mrf
and i have a question to the
commissioner
that's the multi-annual um financial
framework is it ready to
stand up to the challenges of the war
is this a structure that is ready for
this sort of difficult serious crises
and i'm not talking about this war but
any crisis the the answer is clear it is
not well prepared for such challenges we
must change that
the european parliament is now
ready to
answer the calls by the commission and
council to change
the monthly annual financial framework
we need another mechanism it's not about
just wanting or needing more money we
need to rethink some budgetary
mechanisms the budget must be more
flexible
more ready for challenges it cannot send
unused money back to the member states
it this money must stay within the
budget and i hope that this time the
council will understand that so we must
take steps and not only talk about what
the consequences of the war will be
thank you very much
the next one
president instinctively
many
governments
take
tax
measures but this may have
counterproductive
consequences
and this may not benefit the citizens
given the challenge of the war we need
to have more precise instruments apart
from sanctions
we should
put pressure tax pressure on
imported fuels
solidarity should be
measured not in wards but in euros
we should make it clear
germany the netherlands will be able to
support their
companies in case of losses but such
member states are not many
and the attack on ukraine will affect
all of us for example in poland
refugees are mainly
supported by the citizens and the and
local authorities
so
we should
support the citizens and local
authorities that help the refugees
directly
because without this support we will not
be able to continue supporting the
refugees
solidarity
is the
catchword for the last few months we
need to move on to
long-term
and well thought
measures
this is about the future
and i
like to refer to the words of the
previous speaker
the war in ukraine is a an enormous
challenge of
deep
uh economic
management in
europe next generation eu should be the
permanent feature of our system
we should uh
change the stability and growth pack so
that the flexibility is combined with
discipline
thank you the next speaker is a
colleague sandra cagnetti
mr president commissioner madam minister
ukraine
a ukraine belongs to europe and it will
uh belong to europe in the future and we
need to understand
that
ukraine is living in the shadow for uh
but we are in security at the moment we
are not being killed we are not uh
having to hide in sellers and so
it's not a question of uh
calculating the increase in
inflation at the moment i think the
increase inflation is the least that we
can do to help ukraine to win the war
uh none of the uh
leading finance institutions in the
world
are uh
predicting a recession in the european
even the worst case scenario uh talks
about an inflation rate of about two
percent but if we compare it in the in
the baltic country
uh the uh
inflation was 12 the highest increase in
the eu so that it means uh that the
citizens in at the least well-off
countries are
bearing a heavier burden than the richer
countries the longer the war lasts uh
the the lot more will be demanded of
people and so for that reason i'm
calling on europe to act quickly to end
this war in order to win this war
ukraine needs modern heavy weaponry as
quickly as possible and also training
for uh ukrainian soldiers to use these
weapons and at the same time the eu
needs to tighten uh sanctions against uh
the uk there needs to be a full embargo
on um
oil gas and other raw materials to stop
the war machineries and uh
all of these sanctions have to be
implemented without leaving any
loopholes according to the estimates for
the imf uh
the
uk ukraine will need about five billion
dollars
and in order to help them we need to
think about the future and the
international community has to have
special funds for the um
reconstruction after the end of the war
and we have to understand uh that
ukraine cannot win this one because a
victory of uh russia will be a defeat
for europe the next speaker is mrs
dolores montserrat
thank you president my first message is
to the ukrainian people we stand by you
from the pandemic to war
crises are increasing
and
europe's families
workers smes are all affected energy
prices
have shown our weaknesses in
strategic sectors such as energy
we have to start by
decreasing vat and
helping with fuel and electricity
europe has to diversify its sources of
energy for its supply and to strengthen
interconnections for example
gas ducts between spain and the rest of
europe furthermore the war has hit our
food market
because ukraine is the breadbasket of
europe
we have to ensure food supply and
security we have to open up to other
markets in order to ensure that
our
people can be fed we need a cap with
fewer restrictions one which will
guarantee quality food at reasonable
prices
in inflation and increase in electricity
bills and drops in purchasing power are
suffocating millions of europeans
you can't play around with food
the commission has put forward a package
with good
measures however the commission has
still not
received a proposal from the uh spanish
government in order to do something
about gas prices in uh in spain
it doesn't listen it doesn't do what it
says and it abandons spanish people
spain needs less government uh
propaganda and more action people want
lower taxes they want european funds to
get to the real economy and create jobs
and to reduce public
unnecessary uh public expenditure in by
the spanish government europe needs
governments with presidents who will put
the interests of its citizens at uh
above their own thank you very much dear
colleagues we are coming to the hdi
i can
give everybody
who asked for the floor
the floor and i will start with mr
andreas cupideas
mr president the commissioner and your
colleagues
i would like first of all to
congratulate and to thank commission
president for a statement about
sanctions and also about ukraine
reconstruction package
it is our war and we need to take care
first of all about the biggest needs and
this is ukraine
we shall have problems also
but our economies will not go down by 50
it is obvious that reconstruction after
the war will demand big amount of our
money
hundreds of billions or even trillion
euros but it also will open new
opportunities both ukraine and for you
itself for modernization
investment of such scale will create new
jobs we successfully invested trillion
of trillion to fight covet pandemic now
it's time to invest trillion into the
fight against kremlin fascism pandemic
for arms deliveries for a construction
for mitigation of war consequences on
our side we know how to do it and let's
create special fund for reconstruction
of ukraine till the end of june when
decisions on candidate status will be
made ukraine victory is the only way for
all of us to live with peace on european
continent there is no way for a cheap
peace thanks a lot
thank
yes thank you very much president
minister president of the
vice president of the commission
with the covet crisis europe citizens
got a sense that the eu would protect
them and open up new perspectives for
them the creation of the shaw program
the new generation next generation eu
they made the value and importance of
the european union visible not only for
protecting jobs but also in relaunching
europe's economies
this is the kind of decisiveness that
europe citizens expect of the eu now to
uh buffer the social and economic
consequences of this war on their lives
costs of energy costs of food products
the move towards strategic autonomy that
we need to create the necessary
instruments
so
the commission is proposing the creation
of a program
to finance
the move towards energy
autonomy and the transition but of
course we also need to reduce energy
costs for people and companies let's
hope that repower eu will do the job and
we also need to start thinking about a
next generation eu 2.0 that would start
to have a more permanent nature
we cannot allow short-term priorities to
obscure the european priority of the
digital and environmental transitions
thank you
mr
pochinski
thank you very much
as a consequence of the russian
aggression
[Music]
we should finally
realize in france belgium germany
of those
who thought that paying
russia billions we will
convert putin into a democrat there is
no time
for
uh
beautiful words
uh we the only thing that will stop
putin is
decisive sanctions
giving up
gas and
oil from russia
and of course supplies of heavy weaponry
to
ukraine
we should also show uh
decisive complete solidarity with those
uh member states that are now helping
millions
of
refugees slovakia
czech republic and poland and it is a
shame that those countries have not
received
no
funds we
show that solidarity and we also
expect solidarity
from the european commission thank you
thank you mr mick wallace
the social and economic consequences for
the eu
of the russian war in ukraine are
immense
ukraine the eu and the global south are
the biggest losers in this war
the impact on fuel
oil energy and agriculture prices
declining supplies of food
means that many countries will be unable
to pay their foreign debts
the euro has been undermined and we're
asking we're risking an eu-wide
recession
but the u.s sees big opportunities
us treasury secretary janet yellen was
crystal clear on this in her april 13
speech
she detailed how the us will use the imf
to provide conditional assistance to
struggling states friendly to us geo
strategic interests while threatening
sanctions against any countries thinking
of continuing to do any business with
russia
pope francis has come out and
apportioned blame on nato for the war
and questioned the wisdom of supplying
arms to ukraine
nato says they are ready to fuel the war
for years
the us needs the war to reinforce the
unipolar power while ukraine the people
of europe and hundreds of millions in
the global south will pay the price
thank you
thank you colleague
thank you uh organ thomak
thank you president mr commissioner
colleagues 52 billion euros were paid by
the european union starting with january
1st 2022 until the 1st of may this year
to russia i think this figure says it
all
because we buy oil gas and coal
from russia
and in exchange for these
commodities
we support
a country that doesn't respect any
international law
that is why i welcome the new package of
sanctions announced today by president
fonder lyon but i think this is not
enough i think we should do more in
order to weaken russia in order to
persuade putin to give up on this
useless senseless war
i think it's important to
cut imports of oil but it's even more
important to find solutions to
completely stop imports of gas from
russia and to support the member states
so that they can
withstand any provocations in the future
moreover over 5 million citizens from
ukraine had to leave their homes and
they are now in the european union i
hope that
during the future plenary session
president fonder line should announce us
that a refugee fund has been created
there are five million people who are
waiting for concrete support from the
european union member states have done
their best in this crisis situation but
from now on we need to act
institutionally to support these people
to integrate them in our societies until
we shall be able to go back to ukraine
and to rebuild it once this absurd war
is finished those people need their
houses back but they also need a
european perspective and it is only
together that we can build this
perspective through concrete and
immediate actions thank you very much
mr president commissioner dear
colleagues i had great expectations from
today's debate because the title was
consequences on the european union
unfortunately president fonder line did
not speak about the consequences on
member states i will speak on behalf of
a frontline country romania because
romanian citizens of course have been
hospitable generous they received
refugees and this is quite normal to be
uh solidary but what do romanians share
with their ukrainian
refugees
their poverty the smallest
income in their opinion and of course
that we use our budget to help refugees
but what does the european union do has
it concretely supported the member
states such as poland romania slovakia
who received the biggest share of
refugees not really what are the
consequences on the european union the
fact that we have economic
output decrease the fact that
small and medium-sized companies are
being destroyed or decapitalized maybe
this is the time when the commission
should rethink all its plans
with ambition with the responsibility
because we are now in a different
situation commissioner if you ask a
small entrepreneur
uh whenever external factors are
changing his or her plans are also
changing so we should also change unless
we do that we shall destroy our economy
all the supply chains have been
fractured
in vain we have plans on paper if
concretely people are not helped they
will get poorer their income will not
increase
if uh small and medium-sized enterprises
are not supported are not helped to
recover from this double crisis the uh
kovite crisis and now the war on behalf
of the romanians
and again uh
i tell you romanians and people in
general cannot live with our thanks they
need concrete measures
material measures so i want to know
commissioner what will you do concretely
in order to diminish the consequences of
the war on the european union thank you
very much
thank you
angelica nibler is the next speaker
yes thank you very much president
commissioner
colleagues well 70 days now this war has
been dragging on creating
terrible suffering and destruction we
have to do everything possible to end
this war as soon as possible
and to do that we need to ensure that we
raise the pressure on putin
i'm pleased to see the sixth sanctions
package coming it's a courageous extra
step that now the spare back is going
spare bank is going to be cut off from
swift and the oil embargo coming is
definitely the right step
well what will the consequences of this
terrible situation in the ukraine be on
us well
i would agree with the previous speaker
everyone is affected we've got
price spikes we've got high energy
prices we've got a
huge inflation rate
we have to do more at the european union
level and react the lives of our
citizens across the european union
has to be affordable
member states have done a lot they've
reduced vat they've reduced social
contributions
they've provided
subsidies and benefits wherever possible
that's necessary in a situation of
crisis but we have to consider where we
can redirect resources to try and help
people on the ground
the ecb has got an important task ahead
of it as well
price stability is the prime mandate of
the ecb it has to now live up to its
responsibility and
turn the screws on the interest rates
our companies our
small and medium-sized companies need to
see their burdens reduced we need to
ensure that we have security of supply
that's already been raised but when it
comes to stabilizing our energy supplies
our commodities our food supplies
we're now working on uh farming our
environmental focus areas that is the
right step
that is uh the right approach thank you
very much to the commission
costas
we hear
things about
solidarity and the reply
to
russia but that cannot hide the fact
that there are a lot of disagreements
between the governments inside the eu
all of these scenarios follow the eu
logic of the deregulation of
energy of moving away from coal
and of ets that had already
driven up the prices of energy for
months before the war already in greece
as well so behind the fiestas
of the greek government for the lnz
terminal in alexandropolis that is also
a staging point for
imperialism what we see is that we are
substituting russian gas for
u.s
lng and that will also profit greek ship
owners so
all of these uh things mean that we will
have
a heavy toll to pay and it will be paid
by the people and the monopolies will
have a lot of profit
and at the same time we hear from the
imf and others that we will have a new
capitalist crisis the only way out is
for the people's struggle in order to
have
real measures we should stop the ets as
well
as
restart
coal
power plants
and move away from russia thank you that
concludes the catch the eye round with
miss and we conclude with mr gala
president yes thank you very much
president colleagues um
those who help quickly help better and
and so for that reason the timetable of
the parliament on the uh sanction is
more ambitious than that of the council
i uh specifically uh would like to
welcome what the commission has proposed
today as the sixth package
but uh from the view of the parliament
the
oil embargo should be coming now uh the
uh commission
uh should not be uh going to the lowest
common denominator in the council
together the commission and the
parliament can push the council to a
more ambitious plan
and if
we want to uh
uh turn the top off quicker
uh
then
there's a every chance that we will end
the war quicker the uh
worldwide cost of oil is something that
we should share
because of the continuation in fighting
those costs to
increase cost in fuel
refugee support supply of weapons and
that's something that we should also be
uh taking into account in the overall
calculations i think that the commission
together with the presidency should
be helping all member states uh and also
reducing uh the timetable for the oil
embargo
there is enough on the world market but
perhaps not every member state is in a
position to be able to
access these supplies and so for that
reason i do hope that we'll be able to
tighten the schedule
and the demand from the parliament from
the last plenary was that the oil
embargo start now
because then it will help uh to reduce
uh the
uh duration of the war and that is how
we will uh
uh
help our ukrainian friends who are
resisting
thank you very much a colleague and now
we come to the concluding remarks by the
commission and the council and uh
let me give the floor to vice president
czechovidch
thank you very much mr president madame
minister honorable members of the
european parliament
many of you clearly stated that those
with the
broadest shoulders should carry the
biggest load i think that was the quote
from madame hungarius but i very much
felt the same attitude from most of the
honourable members who intervened this
morning and i think that i'm totally uh
in agreement with madame de lange who
said that thanks to support of of this
house eu is indeed leading force in
helping ukraine to defend itself and in
making sure that russia pays exorbitant
political and economic price for this
atrocious war
our major leverage is our political
european unity which is forged in the
debates like this but also our economic
strength which allows us to proceed with
tough unprecedented sanctions which
hurts aggressors more and more
today we proceed with the fixed
package of sanctions and i really would
like to thank you for your encouragement
uh for your support because to quote mr
gary kano and mr galler just a minute
ago
banning oil imports from russia seemed
too difficult just few weeks ago today
we are proceeding today we are doing
just
that and we make sure that we would
proceed in concerted way to have every
single government
on board and as you know this is not an
easy task but
we're working on this unity and i'm very
encouraged by the support to be here in
this house and by the discussions we
have with our member states
i think mr mark is
in very able way that
the political unity indeed is our major
strength and economic power is our major
leverage
several honourable members mr fernandez
mr shirdewan but many others are rightly
reminding us
that our unprecedented sanctions affect
our citizens and businesses in europe as
well
and i want to reassure you that we in
the commissions are also very much
concerned by the high energy prices and
we are looking into all opportunities
how to tackle them and how to
use all the possibilities we have at our
disposal and we will come up with some
proposals and solutions under our
repower plan which will present to you
in coming days it will still be in this
month in may
we are of course looking at other
possibilities how to help economically
and and financially to our member states
and
to our uh citizens mr belkhand mr
albrecht been asking the questions is
our budget fit for war
of course it was
prepared in different times under
different uh circumstances but at the
same time we have to act and we have to
play with the cards we have with the
budgetary mains which are at our
disposals and therefore i thought that i
would bring some figures to you because
through you i believe we can communicate
directly also with our citizens and with
our member states
so far we have 22 out of 27
recovery plans in place and we have this
burst already 70 billion euros to our
member states we hope that in coming
days and weeks we will we will reach the
mark of 100 billion euros which will be
dispensed under our recovery plans and
as i'm sure you know when mr abraham
porter he knows these figures by heart
uh
almost 180 billion 177 billion uh euros
precisely is geared towards climate
goals which of course today
are a purpose for making sure that it
would lower our dependence
uh on on russia we would increase the
the portion of renewables energy in
our systems and in that way subsequently
lower the prices
having mentioned all these figures i
also would like to underline that 220
billion uh euros of loans
are still available there is still this
huge envelope which we want to use and
we are exploring all the possibilities
with the member states how to do that
and this goes into the direction of what
madam nibler said that we have to
repurpose very direct the the means we
have currently uh available on top of
this as madam katanan uh was
highlighting we also identified 17
billion euros of post-pandemic
cohesion events which are still not used
and we proceeded very quickly just to
avoid the situation that this money
which are so badly needed will be
returned back to the
member states and we introduce the
utmost flexibility on urgent need to
support exactly what madame garcia perez
but many others been asking how you can
support the member states uh with the
highest number of refugees like poland
czech republic slovakia also and many
others with housing with education with
health care and the child care just from
the top of my my head what will be of
course very happy to provide with
with the more precise figures i think
poland got more than 288 million uh from
the 17 billion package i mean there was
quite significant some coming to
slovakia i'm sure to romania but i
understand that what we need here is a
little bit more clarity and transparency
and therefore they're going to prepare
the table but we will see uh what is the
overall fund
what are the
lisboards money for each member states
and what is still available so we can
all work with the concrete figures uh to
make it more user-friendly uh thanks to
elisa ferreira my colleague we
established one stop shop and special
task force which can give the advice to
the member states how they can repurpose
and and reuse the money and i hope
that this would this would make it uh
much more faster and easier to use for
our member states and i just want to
pass this message also through you so
the member states are aware and are i
would say ready uh to check what is
available from the budgetary means
we have
of course i totally agree with all of
you that if it comes to
the overall
let's hope as soon as possible post-war
recovery for for ukraine i'm absolutely
sure that europe will be leading force
and will lead the effort here as well
but it's also very clear that this needs
would be enormous we are talking about
hundreds of billions of euros and
therefore we are already now approaching
g7 member states imf world bank
different international financial
institutions because it will have to be
indeed
a collective effort but i agree with all
of you
who underscored in this debate
that there is no price tag if it comes
to freedom if it comes
to liberty if it comes to democracy and
i'm absolutely sure that ukrainian
people first and foremost but also
europe will raise to the challenge to
rebuild free democratic and prosperous
ukraine thank you very much mr president
thank you very much honorable members
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much vice president and
now for the council presidency i'd like
to give the floor to brigitte klinkert
thank you very much president vice
president of the commission ladies and
gentlemen
uh thank you for the debate i think it
was an important and rich debate
on uh schengen to respond to mrs garcia
perez i just want to reassure her
that the french presidency will
undertake every effort to contribute to
the uh uh
smooth running of the zone without
controls at the border we welcome the
efforts by romania and bulgaria in the
uh support being provided to ukrainian
refugees on a minimum
salaries in response to mr satori i can
reassure you that the french presidency
would like to reach an agreement with
the parliament and there will be a trial
log this week even
ladies and gentlemen
the european reaction to the
humanitarian create crisis caused by the
war and also the
scope and
of the measures implemented shows that
our union is uh
more united than ever
all member states without exception have
demonstrated great solidarity with the
millions of people who've been fleeing
the conflict by participating actively
at many levels to this collective effort
of course there is still a great deal to
be done
to
avoid negative impact on our economy our
labor markets and our society and also
to consolidate inclusive and sustainable
growth
no one should feel they are being left
behind in europe
and i would like to highlight our
determination our joint command
commitment as institutions to support
the most vulnerable and the most
affected by the consequences of this war
the council together with the parliament
and the commission is
ready to make its contribution to
face these major challenges and i thank
you once again for the debate
and i thank you very much for listening
[Applause]
thank you very much that closes today's
debate
and
the vote will take at the next
session
there will be a brief suspension session
will be resumed at 11 o'clock
you